this is sprouts cool science produced by
minute videos teaching technique number
one how do I retain my students
attention research suggests that
students attention reduces dramatically
about fifteen minutes into class within
30 minutes
it is often as low as 20% of the
original level and after forty-five
minutes it's almost entirely gone given
that we spend up to 12 years in school
it becomes clear how important it is to
increase the time where your students
actually pay attention one method to
fight boredom and keep attention high is
to reduce the session length you can
break them up into segments with small
breaks in between even if that does not
mean students get back to the initial
high studies show that whenever a new
section begins attention is lifted
dramatically before it drops again a
history teacher for example could break
up Columbus's voyage over the ocean into
four chunks with short one-minute breaks
in between in the first 20 minutes the
teacher could tell the story about the
voyage the next 15 minutes
students could discuss in groups what
could have been dangerous about sailing
during these days then each group could
present their discoveries for another 15
minutes in the last segment the teacher
could complete the students findings and
bring them in context with the actual
risks of Columbus's expedition please
use the comments section below to let us
know what you think if you are a student
tell us if the method improves your
learning if you are a teacher share with
us how you apply it in class we're
releasing updates regularly so don't
forget to subscribe and like us on
Facebook thank you for watching
you